ah what's up guys this prestige here and
we got another divine survival is 8 let
me tell you one thing before we get
started I haven't done divine surviving
like two months I know you guys have
been seen it in what I can call
regularly but I I record a lot so if I'm
a little rusty give me some leisure so
yeah let's just hop into this video so
I've been planning I'm gonna do for this
video I'm gonna do some no more i'm not
going to do as much adventure i'm gonna
make a giant smiley face tower all right
now if we're going to make it the towers
getting made out of oak wood and oak
wood planks and the smiley face can be a
twilight stone and yellow wood so let's
get that so we're going to want to
convert basically all our oak wood that
we have into oak wood planks and then
we're going to want a craft or good deal
of that to stick so let's try that many
into sticks are we got a lot of sick
since we're going to need ladders for a
lot of it I don't even think this is
going to be enough but we'll see alright
that's 24 letters boo boo so yeah I am
actually I'm going to the east coast so
I'm going to be recording a bunch of
videos / putting them up privatizing
them then I'm privatizing them for you
guys to see so I'm hoping that all this
is all gonna work out fine if it doesn't
I do apologize for the next two weeks if
there's not goodness but uh I hope I
hope it'll be good so let's just do this
and see where we're going to need an
entrance so let's let this be the
entrance and yeah we're going to like
you just put to it for now so say we
just tower it all up like this that's a
no music playing music so putting the
beginning alright so let's see how that
is looking eyes all looking good so
let's continue building it for a while
and
come back and see water progresses build
build build so yeah I really I just
haven't done this in a while so
hopefully not video skills or still
adequate to your casa standards and yeah
I this is really just spur the moment i
decided i want to get vide together if
it is up for you guys so I must I must
record so then I just start recording
and it's actually kind of late and mode
I gotta get a bit like 5am to 11pm right
now and most of my family is like a
sleep well parents and so yeah so I got
to be like quiet ish i guess the creeper
oh my clip get at he know um okay i
guess that worked okay you did um yeah i
have dr aight armor that does fall
damage protection so a full set is
complete fall damage protection by that
so we could just build in ham I think
i'm i am placing a lot of them where i'm
not meaning to place them you see all of
those that mean to place so try breaking
them without breaking the wood up i
broke some wood up it Brooks more wood
I'm doing the greatest at this yup aw
dang it let me just break you and let's
go up okay there and there and there and
there and there perfect perfect guys
think that's tall enough it's a pretty
good view of the land well I want to
compete with the mountain a little more
so we're going to go up even higher and
also I have a bunch of ladders so when I
go as far as our lighters can take us
today so the music just like not gonna
play okay whatever what up music screw
which I don't eat you can add in my own
music headed uh
latta de de de de de de de de de
I completely forget what beat that is 10
a 10 a minute I it sounds really
familiar see I just call you making it
our delight get a good view of my land
and stuff let's see how much damage this
does only two hearts awesome let's just
take a look like what that tie would
look like haha alright no one no one
gets to mix penis jokes about this no
one make penis jokes that would be crude
how dare you can think of something like
that I think that's good to make the
smiley face so I'll make this my life a
little bit like a little structure
around it and then I'll make my schmale
parish smallify solder brewskis so I
think let's just put it right here like
elevate a little bit and then yellow
wood I'm gonna need some torch that he
aqui é um so we could do it like that
and that then that's so like it like
this inside this part is making the face
since I got it I got to make it make it
face oh let's jump off the edge there I
did not mean to place the i'm going to
shore it a lot of these blogs so then we
giving it up and then up up
across let's do it with the other one
just make it all units in to the music
was going along so well with this I
think that's good and then when it
crawls up cross up cha let's go look at
what we need to do um alright alright
says ah it's a little bit lopsided and
okay okay nope I don't want to be that
mode alright so let's please put you
right now just uh oh no p however to
want to assure you to show you its check
out the Schick accent break those things
to go fast so I want to place one right
up let's take a look so another one out
hmm actually one sec no I'm gonna put
those there regardless so you do that
and okay so right there then right here
so I gotta go down a bit so i'm going to
show you that and put that there and be
like oh yeah get the smiley face all the
candles no champagne um okay let's break
you and you and we should have oh we
don't haven't even smell fish yet it's
like everything is even except for that
one lock i get is shy so i'll take you
i'll go up boop boop better prepared a
duty duty yeah no no this block mm-hmm
it's this block yes I knew it don't
worry guys I get this all right now
let's implement the smile um
this is going to be a smile so you do
like hats I think that'll look good I
think that looks good yeah election nosh
looks nice and then place you put a slug
tabs so in the eyes I think I'll be put
do want to put out the corners or let's
see let's see what this looks like pop
pop bottles arm sweat I don't even know
something I think it hurts my friends
singing that I think one block eyes
aren't going to be enough do not think
they didn't mean uh hmm looks like a
decent smiley face but we can make it a
little better say we destroy that that
that's Trey that that and I'll have just
enough you yell at would too it's just
enough as I misplace peace ha get up I
needed to show that piece come on don't
fall though I'm gonna fall into my lap
foldable obvious awesome
oh not a piece and let's place place
place place place and please yeah
alrighty that look good that's a nice
smiley face don't you it's a nice my
office ya later I can I'm I'm gonna make
this smile like a larger I think for now
it's good okay cool get a smiley face
now I'm gonna light this up a bit so
that I also to see the music is the
music music is kicking in that's gonna
get a Nolan quick all right let's do
torches torches so see that'll be down
there but I'm gonna like light up like
the entire place let's go take a look at
it from down below right now which is a
smiley face later I might add some
meaningful purpose to it yeah a smiley
face I like it don't you guys like it
like it like it so my penis jokes don't
be mean don't be very cruel of you
Alex yet all right now ruler wasn't true
and what else we were going to do for
this video um I really have no idea how
long this videos been recorded but I
think it's been long enough so our guys
I'm going to sign off hope you enjoy
this like a great comment or subscribe
if you really did it get the end of this
video I think you it deserves want that
so yeah I hope you guys enjoyed it and
peace out